spicy sausage rice whatever you're
cooking the secret to making great food
is to ensure you're locking every last
ounce of flavor in that pan and this
spicy sausage rice does exactly that
[Music]
take these spicy sausages and Pierce
that skin because I want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas Red
Onion less acidic than a big white
Spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because I want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never Rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start the caramelizing
I'm out of my pepper slice around
wasting nothing
I want to see that sort of little core
those tips in the center no fine dice
pepper the rice is going to be cooking
for 20 minutes so I want the veg to sort
of have texture after it's cooked
peppers in a bit of garlic two nice
cloves
just slap down
off of the shell
the garlic in
now we'll turn up the gas get the pan
nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
and then
now start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the Skin's off and the real flavor of
that spicy Italian sausage is gonna come
through what's great about this recipe
is that you can use any type of sausage
to get the flavor and the heat you want
I've gone for the spicy Italian but it's
just as good with mergys or chorizo
a teaspoon
Paprika in give it that really nice
Smoky flavor
rice in and we're going to sort of
basically sear the rice we call it in
the kitchen blasting the rice where we
sort of saute the rice for 30 seconds
and it takes on all that flavor
next white wine
so the wine sort of deglazes the pan and
washes all that flavor from the bottom
of the pan into the rice stock in bring
it up to the boil turn it down and let
it simmer
double stop to Rice turn that gas down
and let it simmer so 12 to 15 minutes
just give it the occasional stir keep an
eye on it now get ready to finish it
sliced spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
spring onions in tomatoes in off with
the gas really important otherwise
everything becomes overcooked flat leaf
parsley in
but look
at the volume in that pan now that is an
amazing way to take spicy Italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
amazing recipes don't necessarily have
to include meat cooking vegetarian
dishes will reduce your food bills
without compromising on taste and flavor
here are three more recipes to satisfy
even the keenest carnivore like me that
will max out on veg and won't break the
bank
starting with spicy black beans with
feta and avocado
[Music]
first in a pan heat olive oil add
chopped onion and Fry until soft
then finely slice garlic and chili
add cumin
cinnamon and black beans then combined
cook together until deliciously soft
these small beans come dried or in tins
and are a great cheap ingredient to make
dishes more substantial to serve dollop
the black bean mixture on crunchy
tortillas
topped with Cube ripe avocado chopped
fresh coriander and crumbled salty feta
cheese
spicy black beans with feta and avocado
a dish has filling Frugal and tastes
fantastic
[Music]
my next great veg recipe is
leaking Greer rosti with fried eggs
[Music]
in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks along
with a knob of butter and seasoning
[Music]
great parvoiled potatoes and Greer a
hard swiss cheese with a great nutty
flavor then combine with the softened
leaves
in a pan heat oil and a little butter
spoon in the potato leek and cheese mix
cook gently until golden and crisp
underneath
then slide onto a plate
flip over and return to the pan to
finish cooking
[Music]
finally for the perfect topping fry two
eggs
and place them on top of the rusty
top with fresh tarragon
[Music]
leaking Greer rosti with fried eggs are
simple but substantial dish that makes
the most of hearty root veg
addition takes as much time to write on
a Blackboard as it does to cook chickpea
cumin and spinach koftas with tahini
dressing
[Music]
in a blender put tin chickpeas cumin
seeds
paprika
and turmeric
and Blitz to a paste
[Music]
next roll spinach in olive oil and chop
finely then add to the chickpea mixture
sprinkling gram flour made from finely
ground chickpeas then shade golf ball
side chunks of the mixture using a spoon
and rest in the fridge when ready to
cook heat oil in a frying pan
shell of fry the copters into golden
brown on all sides
then rest them on kitchen paper to
absorb any excess oil
for an easy dipping sauce mix yogurt
with a dollar about tahini
and a squeeze of lemon
then stir in freshly chopped coriander
a mouth-watering dish that's perfect for
sharing chickpea cumin and spinach
coffees with tahini dressing
[Music]
next recipe is a proper British classic
that's super simple to cook and costs
next to nothing a delicious apple
crumble
crumbles are the perfect way to use
fruit when it's in season there's lots
of it about it's nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruits at its absolute
best
foreign
make a really nice light caramel pan on
nice and low great two apples
[Music]
and this helps to almost sort of pure
the Apple so much quicker there's a lot
of flavor in the skin so don't worry
about peeling the fruit whether it's
pears plums peaches flavors in the skin
[Music]
start the camera a couple of tablespoons
of sugar the sugar helps to get rid of
the tartness in the Apple a touch
Cinema that starts to make it a little
spicy open up your vanilla just scrape
out all those seeds now this just makes
it light and fragrant all those seeds in
to the Sugar We're making caramel be
patient and always swirl the dish
instead of stirring it
when the sugar goes Brown add the Apple
starts to sort of cool down the caramel
but it gives it a really nice sort of
caramelized puree apples almost
disintegrating
smells incredible turn the gas down
slice up two apples it's a crumble
That's Got No Frills straight forward no
faffing around no peeling on the skin I
want them to sort of stand out from the
camera apples in
now those nice thick chunks of Apple
sort of almost bedding itself into the
puree
dried cranberries gives it that nice
sort of shock in the texture
sweet
chewy I want it to sort of taste zesty
spicy so sit the lemon zest on top of
your apples and cranberry fresh lemon
juice over and that just gives that
extra acidic kick takes the Cranberries
the apples the caramel and the cinnamon
to another level turn the gas off
that says let's concentrate on the
crumble flowering
a couple of tablespoons of Demerara
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy butter in
give that a nice little rub what we're
looking for is like a
breadcrumb mixture lightly season it
with a touch of cinnamon
and the dinner sugar sort of helps to
get a nice fine crumble mix and it stops
the butter from sort of melting in that
flour so that's the basic crumble mix
but I'm not finished yet muesli
two-thirds crumble
one third muesli mix that in if you
haven't got muesli then crunchy granola
works brilliantly too lovely
now start off in the center
and work your way around
I want the crispiness on the top the
puree on the bottom of the caramel and
then the texture in the center a good
tip
and the gas back on I want it bubbling
before it goes in the oven because then
you just got to cook the top so as soon
as you see that caramel starting to
Bubble down the side in she goes let's
go
all right
bake it 200 degrees Celsius for 12 to 14
minutes until golden brown
smells amazing
[Music]
still bubbling
and look at it a delicious but very
simple crumble with apples at their
absolute best beautiful
[Music]
foreign